this guy is a revelation he has been
phenomenal this year he's been terrific
ever since being drafted to the rams in
2017
he completed a triple crown season most
catches most touchdown catches most
receiving yards in the league he's being
mentioned as an mvp candidate and why
not he's playing on monday night
football to wrap up super wild card week
and he is the pride of yakima washington
now here playing for the los angeles
rams he is none other than all pro
cooper cup how are you cooper
hey i'm good rich thanks for having me
you bet i i i hope that introduce did i
miss anything and then i mean you've
done so much i i don't think i'm good
gracious yeah you'd have to you have to
do all that well maybe do you want to
host the oscars too cooper that job's
open i mean you could do it all do you
want to do that
um i'm all good you sure i mean that's
you know it's march you know this will
be in the part of your your off season
you could host the oscars don't you
just enjoy some time with the family
okay there you go very good so uh to
what do you attribute the remarkable
personal success that you've had this
year along with your team i understand
it is a team game there is no i in
cooper or cup but to what do you owe
this uh explosion that we've seen from
you yeah this year man i mean i i don't
know if you can
we could sit here we've only got we've
only got 10 minutes written i don't know
if i have enough time to go through all
these different all the people have been
a part of just
putting together a great year like
you've touched on them before i mean
none of this happens without an
incredible group of people around you
incredible football players
you know receivers
more than any other position in the
ultimate team game receiver relies on
the other 10 guys to do their job before
i can get the ball
you know everyone else has to do their
job yeah o line that needs to be a block
up front running backs they got to put
pick up blitzes
other receivers here i'll be able to run
great routes feel or draw coverage
really do stuff to
allow me to do what i do
and then correct i can you know put the
ball um in the right spot so
so much credit to the just the guys that
i get to play with day in and day out
coaches that put us in great spots um
you know it's uh it's a huge credit just
people have around you and so you know
we talk so much in my end of the
business about chemistry and it is such
an esoteric thing but what is yours with
matthew stafford did you have it right
away when you first met him
it's something definitely just it's a
growing thing you guys just continue to
collaborate with each other talk to each
other about what you're seeing out there
how you can uh be more efficient um just
try to be on the same page in terms of
how you're seeing coverage and this is
how you want to attack it you know what
what kind of things does matthew like
what kind of throws does he like to make
and um you know as you can have been
able to get reps together and kind of
talk through those things it just
continues to grow when did that happen
immediately upon his acquisition by the
team when did that happen for you no i
think it's it you know i think during oh
chains really a little bit of a grasp of
what that could look like um you know
just you know you don't get a ton of
reps during a shortened otas
that we had this year but um i think the
time that we spent between being able to
talk about things and trying to maximize
every rep even when we're not in there
you know taking the reps but we're
watching
and seeing it together i think that's
made a big big difference for us
and uh you know again cooper uh and i i
know you're a team guy so i apologize in
advance by asking all these individual
um
you know achievement awards that do
require a team effort but
um you are one of only five guys who
received all 50 votes for the first team
all-pro and you were being mentioned
viably at the receiver position as an
mvp candidate what do you think of when
you hear that just maybe as the kid from
yakima let's go in that respect right
there
yeah it's uh i mean it's obviously an
incredible honor um the names that
you get to kind of see your name beside
i think that's just something i've got
so much respect for the guys in this
league you guys have played in this
league are doing it right now at such a
high level
but also guys have you know come before
and set the standard in this league and
really made this league what it is um
you know i've i've loved watching
football from my earliest years i love
this game it's just so much respect for
it so um just being a place where
you know i'll be able to see my name
alongside some of those things it is
it's an incredible honor and it's uh
it's doing no short part to the people
i've i've got around me and
the position i've been able to play be
placed in and i'm just glad i could uh
be a part of stepping into that role and
uh being able to produce the stream and
i and i heard one of your answers this
year about uh walking everybody through
a play um a big touchdown that you had
you know the x's and o's and you knew
everything soup to nuts about all of it
and mcveigh is a guy who remembers
everything that he had for breakfast 19
million years ago
what is it like when the two of you guys
talk ball
cooper it's fun
it's great being able to dive into kind
of the deeper things the deeper uh you
know nuances of this game where uh you
know you're not talking about just
um you're not talking about just drawing
up a a pattern or anything like that but
you're talking about attacking
individual um you know individual
individual rules of a defense individual
leverages and um you know little things
that you see within uh the schematics of
you know how one team plays you know 33
week and you can say hey this team's
playing just a little more match here
this these hook players are pushing
through or whatever
whatever it is but being able to be on
the same page of um understanding that
there's greater detail that can be you
know gone into that you can um you know
be able to take advantage of things that
you know sometimes other people can't
because you just aren't uh
able to see or kind of
get to that level of detail with the
amount of time that you have in the
course of the week but just the time
that we've spent being able to dive into
those things it's been a lot of fun
cooper cop few more minutes left with
the cooper cup of the los angeles rams
here on the rich eisen show the
challenge of facing an opponent that
knows you you know them third time
around is what what do you got for me on
that one
obviously i mean you put so many reps
together now um you know it's being able
to you know drive yeah the idea of what
works for them what kind of things
they're going to kind of bring to the
table again um you know what kind of
things you might expect to see uh
you know i think there's something to be
said about you know going against
someone
um over and over in terms of individual
dbs or linebackers what have you um
getting a feel for how they play the
game but it's in the same way they get
to have that same experience with you
and so uh trying to be ahead of the
curve and
um in terms of
you know being able to adapt to kind of
the changes that you might think they're
gonna make and um it just adds another
layer to another layer to this game
where you're really game plan each other
but you gotta play off of what you also
are expecting them to do where uh you've
got a lot of reps against them what
about the idea that uh they're expecting
the rams to make sure that you're found
by stafford what about that that the
general sense of playoffs is to remove
that
from another team's repertoire and you
are that guy
cooper yeah yeah i mean at the end of
the day it's uh you know you just have
to execute your job for the best of your
ability and uh you know being able to
identify when you know
when you know teams might want to tilt
coverages or do doubles or win body
presence and stuff like that but you
know we've got so many good receivers on
this team so many guys that can make
plays i think it really
makes it a challenge on a defense to do
that you got you know dell and van
there they can stretch the field they
can do all that stuff so
you know we've got guys that can they
got guys that can do some really good
stuff for us and uh makes it tough to
try to take one guy out of the game okay
before i let you go cooper cup and to
your into your friday is there any
conversation you have at all
you saw what the bucks did last year you
know where the super bowl is this year
you know where you're playing monday
night you know whose house it is as they
say
so do you have that conversation just
openly like let's just do this it
happened last year let's go back to back
and winning
it all in our home building for the
super bowl
you know i think that's all obviously
that's the ultimate goal at the end of
the day you know you always know that
that's the pinnacle of this season as
there's the ultimate goal of every team
that comes in this year um there's not
much talk that needs to be done i mean
if you have to come in and talk about
the fact that you want to play in a
super bowl then probably the wrong guys
uh in the building so you know we got we
know what we want to accomplish this is
more of a mentality of taking things a
day at a time and trying to win each
individual day each week
and then be able to uh you know move
forward as those days come as those
weeks come so
kind of a a shortened view that just
allows us to be focusing on the details
and stacking blocks and uh knowing that
the ultimate goal obviously will play
you know that that big game is so by the
end of the year well congrats on putting
your name in mvp status man
congrats on that you are most welcome it
really is amazing to watch and
last one for you how long do you keep
the beard is this a is this a playing
season thing or or is this a year-round
thing it'll probably be for the season
i'll i'll uh you know i'll have to
reflect on that when the season whenever
the season does come doing it i'll
reflect on that and see what we end up
on here
my wife my wife's gonna have a big stay
on that i mean of course but this is a
maintenance thing it looks like to me to
be very honest it's a maintenance issue
yeah yeah it is a maintenance issue and
you know if she really likes it i'm only
putting the time to keep it looking uh
okay looking relatively nice all right
will you let stafford know i wore
georgia hat on nfl network if he's not
aware of it because i mean
they actually did it and it wasn't fun
so just let him know i actually came
through cooper thanks for the time man i
appreciate it yeah of course let's do
this again you bet that's cooper cop
there's nobody better right here on the
rich eisen show mv monday night football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here